en este vídeo vamos a dar comienzo al
tema llamado suma total
de cuadrados
también representado por la sigla s 7
también se lo llama suma de cuadrados
total suma de cuadrados total de ahí
viene la sigla está mencionada ese 7
bueno de qué se trata todo esto
antes que nada vamos a trabajar vamos a
borrar esto vamos a trabajar con un
también un nuevo concepto que va a ser
llamado la gran media una gran media
es una equis barra barra es decir es la
media de todas las medias que podamos
tener de los distintos grupos para
calcular esto muy sencillamente tenemos
que sumar todos los elementos y
dividirlo por la cantidad de elementos
que tenemos por lo tanto vamos a tener
x la barra es igual a vamos a hacerlo
con los respectivos colores 3 2 1
todo esto sumándose de verdad
534 siempre sumándose estoy sumando por
colores cada grupo cierto
5 6 y 7 todo esto también sumado y esto
lo vamos a dividir por la cantidad de
elementos con los que trabajamos en este
caso son 9
por lo tanto tenemos 3 25 16 65 11 314 4
18 18 523 23 más 7 30 36 36 / 9 es igual
a 4 es decir que la media de las medias
o la gran media es igual a 4 y otra
forma de verlo en la siguiente nosotros
sabemos que la media del grupo 1 es
igual a tres más dos más uno dividido
tres que es igual a dos la media del
grupo dos
es igual a 5 3 4 / 3 que es igual a 4
mientras que la media del grupo 3 es
igual a 5 + 6 + 7 / 3 que es igual a 6
ahora sí realizamos la media de estas
tres medias tendríamos lo siguiente un
sabor ahora que tenemos
el 6 por acá 4 por acá y 2 por acá ahora
si hacemos 2
4 vamos a hacer así y esto lo sumamos
y lo dividimos por 3 vamos a ver que
obtenemos el mismo resultado que tenemos
acá 4 la media de las medias 2 4 6 6 6
12 12 / 34 es decir la gran media es
igual a la media de las medias y ahora
lo que nosotros estamos trabajando qué
es
suma de cuadrados total
se la va a reconocer como la distancia
la distancia de cada uno de estos
elementos
a la gran media
la distancia que hay entre estos
elementos entre cada uno de estos
elementos y la gran media este 4
el cuadrado mejor dicho de esa distancia
verdad de ahí viene la suma de cuadrados
tenemos entonces tres menos cuatro más
fíjense vamos a hacer dos menos cuatro
más y hacerlo con los colores también de
cada grupo vamos a hacer así
3 - cuatro más dos menos cuatro más
1 - 4 y todos estos van a estar al
cuadrado por eso estamos buscando el
cuadrado de las distancias después vamos
a tener en un color verde
5 - 4
al cuadrado más tres menos cuatro al
cuadrado más
4 - 4 al cuadrado y claro que éstos
siempre se están sumando es cierto esto
siempre estamos sumando nada más que yo
lo sigo abajo por lo tanto
abajo vamos a tener lo siguiente
5 - 4 al cuadrado más
al cuadrado más 7 menos 4 al cuadrado
ahora resolviendo todas estas
operaciones tenemos 3 - 4 - 1 - 1 al
cuadrado 1
sigo acá abajo
2 - 4 - 2 - 2 al cuadrado es 4
1 - 4 - 3 - 3 al cuadrado es 9 tenemos 5
- 4 11 al cuadrado vamos a hacerlo en
verde 1 al cuadrado es 13 menos 4 - 1 -
1 al cuadrado también es 14 menos 400 al
cuadrado es 0
y ahora vamos con los del tercer grupo
que tenemos 5 menos 41 nuevamente uno al
cuadrado 16 menos 422 al cuadrado 4 más
7 menos 433 al cuadrado 9
esto nos da como resultado
es decir que la suma la suma de
cuadrados total es igual a 30
y este 30 esta suma de cuadrados total
es muy importante es un dato muy
importante que conseguimos porque
supongamos que nosotros queremos
averiguar los grados de libertad
de libertad
de esta distribución de esta serie de
datos nos dice que si nosotros conocemos
este valor
la suma de cuadrados total o mejor dicho
si conocemos la
gran media o la media de las medias
al realizar esta operación
no en realizar esta operación
solo teniendo 8 datos en vez de los 9 si
nosotros poner supongamos que ponemos
que no tenemos este dato pero conocemos
la gran media conocemos que su valor es
4 nosotros podríamos averiguar este otro
valor
podríamos averiguarlo sin ningún
inconveniente y decir que es un 7
utilizando esta fórmula de la suma de
los cuadrados totales conociendo también
el valor este diríamos entonces que los
grados de libertad en este caso
son 8 y otra forma de ver porque son 8
es la siguiente vamos a borrar acá para
esclarecer un poco todo este asunto
dijimos que teníamos vamos a hacerlo
todo en un mismo color ahora 321 5 3 4 5
6 7 supongamos que nosotros o no
supongamos si nosotros tenemos la
certeza de que tenemos
digamos m columnas y tenemos
vamos a borrar esto y tenemos n filas
la forma de ver los grados de libertad
sería muy sencillo haciendo la cantidad
de columnas por la cantidad de filas
menos una unidad
esto es en nuestro caso tenemos tres
columnas por tres filas menos uno es
igual nueve menos uno que es igual a 8
es decir obtenemos exactamente el mismo
valor
que dijimos antes